Fran Ferrand bonjour bonjour Véronique
merci de nous accueillir sur votre lieu
de travail V lieu de travail à
savoir voilà le studio des des des
nouvelles urgentes des infos alors là on
va croiser les doigts pour qu'il ne se
passe rien pendant 20 minutes calme PL
sur la planète pour être un peu
tranquille on va écoutez on va faire un
peu mieux connaissance avec vous vous
êtes actuellement donc sur les ondes de
repain depuis ça va faire 11 ans votre
émission s'appelle au cœur de l'histoire
de 14 à 15h du lundi au vendredi vous
êtes aussi à la télévision sur France 3
sur France 3 nombre d'un doute c'est une
mensuelle c'est pas tout à fait une
mensuelle j'aimerais bien que ce le soit
ouais pour l'instant c'est quoi alors
c'est toutes les 5 semaines environ
d'accord et l'ombre d'un doute vous vous
racontez-moi un peu le principe en alors
le le principe c'est de faire rayonner
de faire briller un lieu en quelque
sorte alors nous sommes allés
successivement à l'Élysée au Louvre à
Venise à Bordeaux très récemment à
Fontaine Bau et bientôt nous allons
emmener les téléspectateurs à Florence
l'émission vient d'être tournée là on
s'est beaucoup amusé et puis on ira à
Vienne à versaill dans les châteaux de
la Loire ah versaill est prévu versaill
est prévu pour le mois de mars ah ben
écoutez c'est moin savoir on en
reparlera bien sûr ok vous vous êtes un
amoureux de versaill on peut dire ça
vous y avez même vécu oui j'y ai vécu
par
passionion vevre à versaill parce que
j'aimais ce domaine et que je voulais
être juste à côté du du parc en fait je
suis allé vivre rue de satori pendant 4
ans j'y serais bien resté car ça a été 4
années absolument merveilleuses
malheureusement avec la radio ça n'était
plus gé compé long dans les
embouteillages et j'avais toujours peur
d'être en retard et est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas aussi resté à un moment pour
écrire votre livre sur le fameux Gérard
V voilà c'était à cette époque alors le
livre ce n'était pas le livre sur Gérald
là c'était l'ouvrage qui s'appelait ils
ont sauvé Versailles qui racontait
l'histoire du château depuis la
Révolution jusqu'à nos jours d'accord et
le livre sur Gérald vous l'avez écrit en
fait dans le cadre de ce livre il y
avait un chapitre sur Gérald et Florent
alors j'étais allé les rencontrer
d'ailleurs j'étais allé passer une
semaine à giverni à avec les verkem ce
que vous racontez d'ailleurs dans livou
formidable c'était vraiment un moment
extraordinaire et notamment cet
entretien qui a duré plusieurs heures
d'affilé en tête à tête et je voyais
parce qu'on était en plein hiver c'était
la première semaine du 21e siècle
d'ailleurs je voyais le le le jour
tomberé sur les jardins de claudeemy et
je n'osais pas ni allumer la lumière ni
même demander à à à me munir d'un stylo
d'un d'un papier parce que je ne voulais
pas interrompre le maître qui pour une
fois avait décidé de se livrerord ah
parce qu'il se livre Armand et à
l'époque il refusait absolument de
parler de versaill hein il était oui oui
il était totalement braqué et quand on
quand on citait ne sa que le nom de
versaill il se il se rembrunissait et
puis un jour son épouse Florence était
parti à Paris et il me dit alors que
voulez-vous savoir sur versaill
incroyable et je lui ai dit tout il lu
dit j'espère que vous avez du temps
devant vous et ça a duré des heures et
voilà et c'était pas du tout prévu et
vous avez tout gardé en tête j'ai essayé
le plus possible j'ai oublié des choses
forcément voilà d'accord donc euh vous
êtes revenu sur vos vos amours
versaillais donc avec la sortie de ce
livre Le Dictionnaire amoureux de
Versailles qui fait partie d'une
collection très importante plein de de
grands écrivains ou ou pas forcément
écrivains d'ailleurs S sont essayés
est-ce qu'on peut pouvez nous dire quels
sont les j'ai envie de dire les règles à
suivre quand on vous demande d'écrire un
livre comme ça cette collection est très
particulière cette collection des
dictionnaires amourux chez plomb il
s'agit en fait et c'est Jean-Claude
Simoen qui l'a créé il y a une bonne
dizaine d'années
euh le principe c'est de demander à un
spécialiste d'un sujet ou de nous donner
sa vision une vision extrêmement
personnelle et subjective donc quand on
vous parle du grand canal ou de la
galerie des Glaces il s'agit pas de
raconter ce qu'on ferait dans un
dictionnaire classique il faut raconter
ce qu'on y a vécu soi-même ce qu'on a
appris que les autres ne savent pas et
ce qu'on en pense donc ça demande une
espèce c'est une énergie folle et c'est
une exigence incroyable que de pouvoir
livrer sur chacun des aspects de cet
énorme sujet qui est le domaine de
Versailles en l'occurrence de pouvoir
livrer un point de vue tout à fait
unique et personnel et j'ai j'ai moi
j'ai alors certains respectent plus ou
moins évidemment la la règle hein on
connaît des dictionnaires amoureux qui à
mon avis sont très peu amoureux entre
nous soit dit mais moi j'ai vraiment ça
c'est j'ai envie de dire c'est à la fois
ma qualité et mon défaut c'est que j'ai
hor du hors sujet et quand on me demande
un exercice j'essaie de M plier et donc
là j'ai vraiment joué le jeu et ça a été
à la fois un travail extraordinaire
exténement on peut dire parce que se
reposer cette question sur chaque sujet
vous imaginez on va parler de le NRE on
va parler de le brin c'est pas la vie de
le brin qu'on demande c'est ce que moi
je pense et ce qu'il m'a apporté dans ma
vie relation c'est ça donc c'est asse
étonnant à faire et en même temps je
pense que c'est le plus bel exercice
qu'on puisse imaginer et je me suis
rendu compte à mesure que s'écrivait ce
livre c'est presque 600 pages quand même
c'est un beau Bou je me suis rendu
compte que c'est un peu une sorte
d'autoportrait qui se dessine en creux
finalement j'étais en train d'écrire sur
Versailles et sans l'avoir vraiment
décidé c'est sur moi que je finissais
par écrire d'accord c'est rigolo ça ah
oui c'est et vous avez démarré quand ce
travail alors ça do'écire je n'ai pas
été très bonne élève sur ce ce coup
puisque on j'ai j'ai rendu le manuscrit
4 ans après avoir signé le le contrat
parce que je n'arrivais pas à m'y mettre
vraiment j'avais tellement à dire et en
même temps je plçais la barre S ou que
je ne voyais pas vous savez il y avait
un côté procrastination je me disais
mais j'y viendrai je m'y mettrai en
temps utile et le temps passait et un
jour j'ai dit alors là il faut vraiment
s'y mettre et j'ai écrit le livre on va
dire en un an et demi à peu près don 6
mois très intense à la fin comme par
hasard parce que voilà je m'y étais pris
un peu tard ça a été vraiment les 6
derniers mois on peut dire que j'ai vécu
dans versaill et dans mon univers
versaillet et moi qui me disait je vais
écrire ce dictionnaire amoureux entre
guillemets pour me débarrasser de
Versailles parce que ça fait 35 ans que
je suis dans ce sujet il faut tourner la
page mais en fait le résultat ça a été
que j'ai passé 6 mois d'immersion totale
et que depuis que le le livre est sorti
je ne parle plus quasiment que de
versaill ou bon après ça ça va se calmer
mais d'accord et alors moi ce que j'ai
beaucoup aimé c'est la façon très bon
comme on disait personnelle et et
originale d'aborder les sujets et et ça
un côté très concret je trouve bon vous
aimez beaucoup pierre de
nolac vous êes aidé de de de plein
d'amis à vous finalement trois grands
conservateurs à versaill Pierre de nolac
évidemment qui a remis versaill à la
mode à une époque où le Château Les
Jardins était complètement oublié nolac
a rendu à versaill son histoire et du
coup son attrait ensuite il y a eu 50
ans plus tard Géral van derkem dont on a
parlé qui a remeublé le château et puis
et c'est la chance de notre époque nous
avons aujourd'hui un grand conservateur
en chef qui s'appelle Béatrix sa et qui
je pense donne à versaill un grand
rayonement
oup de bellesositions alors justement
puisque vous en parlez belles
expositions ah oui mais vous parlez pas
forcément des exposition d'art
contemporain ah non alors par là vous
donnez votre avis sur moi je suis contre
ça je suis pas contre l'art contemporain
parce que là ça évidemment il y a
quelques journalistes qui ont commencé à
m'épingler en disanton euh même si je ne
suis pas un spécialiste d'art
contemporain je le reconnais mais en soi
j'ai rien contre je suis contre
l'utilisation des monuments historiques
comme écrin à des expositions d'art
contemporain et notamment de Versailles
qui sert essentiellement à faire monter
la côte d'artistes vivants et ce qu'il y
a de plus choquant en l'occurrence c'est
l'affaire Jeff k puisque là on a AFF
faire non seulement à un artiste vivant
en cours de de construction mais en plus
il a un point de vue sur l'art et sur le
monde qui sont qui est exactement
l'opposé de l'esprit versaillet
c'est-à-dire qu'il est venu faire un
énorme pied de nez à la tradition et au
grand style versaillais et il fait une
exposition dont le but même est de
ridiculiser les lieux ça je trouve pas
ça bien du tout et je trouve incroyable
que les gens n'aient pas davantage
réagis à l'époque et vous terminez en
invitant les gens à venir vivre à
versaill oui oui pourquoi pas et vous
vous comptez venir alors moi je suis
allé vous savez en 2000 je suis allé
vivre à Versailles par amour des lieux
c'est assez rare qu'on vienne
s'installer quelque part juste parce
qu'on a envie voyez c'était pas les
hasards de la vie c'était la volonté de
vivre aux portes au March du domaine
donc je suis venu m'installer rue de
satori ça a été 4re années merveilleuses
tous les soirs quasiment à toutes les
saisons on allait faire le tour du grand
canal à vélo enfin c'était c'était des
moments magnifiques malheureusement mon
emploi du temps actuel et toutes mes
obligations à Paris font que je je ne
peux plus faire ça mais je ne désespère
pas un jour d'y retourner oui pourquoi
pas j'aimerais bien bon ben écoutez ça
serait sympa de vous y voir c'est une
ville merveilleuse versaill on peut dire
que on a tendance malheureusement à ne
parler toujours que du château des
jardins du musé
vous faites un un chapitre sur la
villeàis rendez hommage au maire de Dam
ou dam qui est un monsieur merveilleux
oui oui tout à fait et donc j'ai j'ai
essayé effectivement de de faire une
sorte de coup de chapeau final à la
ville et je dis au au lecteurs deux
choses d'abord si vous êtes visiteur du
château de versaill prenez le temps
d'aller voir un peu la ville allez vous
promener au parc Balbi allez voir le
musée Lambinet all à l'osmoèque aller à
la maison de Madame Élisabeth sur sur la
Montreuil sur laavenue de Paris c'est
voilà ça fait partie des choses à faire
et puis si vous êtes d'une façon plus
générale parisien pourquoi ne venez-vous
pas vous installer à versaill alors je
sais que les Versaillais ont horreur
qu'on dise ça ils sont bien contents de
profiter d'être tranquille dans cette
dans cette ville mais en même temps je
sais que peu de gens suivront le conseil
et que ceux qui vont le suivre seront
heureux alors il fallait c'était presque
une mission ou une mission carrément
écoutez C
il aura repuplé versaill et ensuite oui
alors pour revenir à je vous disais le
côté concret même pratique vous vous
faites un si je sais pas si on peut dire
un chapitre une une des lettres dans le
a vous faites oui un article entrée
comme on dit dans les dictionnaires ou
sur le mot accueil vous expliquez bien
concrètement comment se rendre à
versaill et cetera enfin c'est vraiment
un manuel inviatique voilà moderne
actuelle et et plein de vie oui j' qui
donne vraiment envie ah ben tant mieux
ou suis ravi que vous disiez ça parce
que mon but c'était aussi de donner aux
gens non seulement l'envie de venir à
Versailles mais l'envie d'y revenir
parce que vous avez énormément de je
parle en France notamment vous savez que
une immense majorité des visiteurs du
château de versaill sont des étrangers
en fait hein puisque les Français bouent
un peu ces lieux pour une raison simple
c'est que généralement ils y sont allés
une fois ils ne ils n'ont pas préparé
leur visite ils arrivent un peu tard
dans la journée ils se retrouvent dans
une file interminable ensuite ils sont
ils sont bousculés si je puis dire dans
cette espèce de boulevard touristique
qui est le grand appartement la galerie
des glaces et l'appartement de la reine
ils ressortent de là hberlué un peu
sonné avec l'impression d'avoir perdu du
temps de n'avoir pas vraiment vu ce qui
les intéressait et ils en gardent une
assez mauvaise image donc ce que je leur
dis c'est préparez votre
visite entrez par les jardins allez
visiter d'abord les Trianon organiser
vos conférences visiter les endroits
qu'on ne voit peut-être pas toujours
mais tout ça se prépare àavant grâce à
internet ou même simplement par
téléphone mais une visite à Versailles
ça se prépare il faut du temps on vient
pas à Versailles pour 4hes on vient à
versaill au moins pour une journée si
possible pour deux et voilà une fois
qu'on a toutes ces peut dormir à
versaill aussi bien entendu très bien
ben écoutez merci pour ce ce livre qui
va éclairer et qui qui reste comment
dire vous arrivez à dire encore des
choses nouvelles quoi je sais je sais
vous savez vous ne pouvez pas passer 35
ans de votre vie avec une passion comme
celle de Versailles sans finir par
accumuler un certain nombre de petites
connaissances de petites choses qui ne
sont généralement pas dites et bien moi
je les ai j'ai essayé parce que le
problème c'est que maintenant que le
livre est refermé je me rends compte que
j'ai oublié des choses ben Presque Oui
mais en tout cas j'ai essayé de livrer
ce qu'on dit pas d'habitude et ben voilà
et je vous en remercie Merci à VOUS
Franck Ferrand à
bientôt